[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
who are you
i'm third chair now dave
hey what's going on
i'm third chin
now you're not
[Music]
you're dreaming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
love
[Music]
i could never make it
[Music]
now
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
wonderful and uh that's uh tuesday and
look who decided to show
ahoy at dave landau he's here i figured
i'd introduce him hey
he's well you feeling better i am yes
with a little bit of that daylight
savings flu uh yes that's what it was
we'll call it that that messed everybody
up yesterday i was like i'm so tired
there's that moment of panic that you
always have when you realize that the
the clock on your phone doesn't match
the clock on the microwave you're like
i've been going by microwave clock
my microwave clock doesn't match my oven
clock that's how bad i am where i'm like
why are you two minutes apart also my
microwave clock i can't really read it
because uh i open it a lot and stand in
front of it for extended periods of time
till my head hurts did i take my parents
the most terrifying thing ever we're
gonna get right into what we need to
discuss today but their microwave was
broken they just had to have it fixed
this week do you know how it do you know
how it broke
it would only run when the door was open
so it was just the cancer muscle yes it
was the cancer microwave yeah with just
stuff splatting out of it it was a
cancer aid
cancer pool
cancer wave enjoy it lg cancer so
how did they find out
i mean just try with the door they're
like things they're like things aren't i
don't know my mom's french canadians
things are not that they're not getting
it's warm now oh good we don't need a
new one yeah
every time you go to make some orville
redenbacher you're like marvin home
alone
it's worth it just colonel shooting like
bullets through your house
backfire
all right we have a lot to get to today
but let me tell you before anything else
uh because
we are directly going against the white
house's orders on russia ukraine so if
ever you miss this show
and you say hey where's the show we
haven't let you know that we're missing
a day we're missing a week
it's streaming live on rumble uh monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern of
course mug club live with credit.com
club where we do an additional 45
minutes to an hour every day but if it's
not on youtube it doesn't mean that
we're gone nothing would make me happier
than all of you right now
to go over to my club in rumble but well
one that's not in the cards uh we'll be
talking today about uh
a couple of things
rachel levine could be a woman of the
year wow fantastic so that's important
but uh we'll also be talking about the
left here uh you know jen saki just gave
some marching orders to tick-tockers to
go out and make sure that they
they are when i say accurate i mean make
sure that they propagate the talking
points that the white house wants
specifically on russia ukraine
and then uh condemn russia for you know
censoring media for trying to set a
narrative for silencing dissidents when
that process is happening here in the
united states uh to an alarming degree
and it's amazing it's kind of like the
you know breitbart talked about the old
olinsky tactic one-on-one accuse the
other side of doing exactly what it is
that you are doing and that's a scary
thing right now it's very hard to find
accurate information on russia and
ukraine just to be clear no one here is
a putin apologist think he's a dick okay
so my question to you before we move on
and you know i was going to ask if you
think that the tick tockers have
informed you on gas prices but more
importantly you know the goal of this
show i want to make sure we're always
sort of true north it's obviously
supposed to be entertaining but the goal
is to equip you
hopefully
with information so that you're able to
go forward and have these conversations
whether it's inflation whether it's gas
prices whether it's abortion whatever
the topic is i'm going to try and do
that today and let me know if you feel
that it's helped you with that comment
below if this program has specifically
helped you to have conversations with
people in your life because if not then
that means that we're not doing our job
that's why we also make all references
available at loudourcredit.com or in the
pinned comment if you're on youtube okay
before we move on gerald a how are you i
am well how are you sir better now that
i know it's daylight savings time right
so you know what time it is and your
body has adjusted in one day yeah no it
hasn't do you know what time it is it's
time to be tired
why is it so sunny yeah
so still the sun i can't believe it's
still today what
and dave of course you know who i am i
introduced him but uh let's uh move on
from this uh first thing
is this russian orthodox priest
was happy about being cut off from the
western world and i want you to watch
this and understand a couple of things
first off there's blatant hypocrisy
which we'll get to but he's not entirely
wrong and he's actually echoing in a
peaceful way what you hear a lot from
isis or what they would use in
recruiting tapes as far as how they
condemn the west so let's go to um
priest ron swanson to hear what he has
to say
is
foreign
[Laughter]
and men with breasts
as a man with a mustache breasts
[Music]
i come by these uh men titties these
mobs honestly
and mustache take years of work and
self-neglect yes these were grown of
self-hatred yes or many many moons these
were grown not bought you can't buy this
self-respect in a store
tits wait until he sees buzzfeed
bowlesley uh painting and
period blood he wouldn't even have a
chip for that no he would not understand
it he's not wrong no he's not wrong i
will tell you you know
transgender ideology and rampant
pornography these are absolutely
shameful exports of the west and you may
look you you may not agree with them but
you have to understand that's how a lot
of the world sees it again isis these
peep taliban they would say look at the
west look they you know how they
recruited people for isis they would
just sit them down for you know 35
minutes in front of meet the kardashians
neither say more
yeah
that or the whole we're going to behead
you and then i'm like yeah i'm on your
team right now
i guess we deserve it at some point
no it's true there is a lot of
i don't even understand who makes money
in porn anymore
i guess i don't really know i mean i
guess it's like gotta be the top tier
because from what i understand they're
just why buy the cow you know what i
mean right yeah that's what i think is
free well one thing that you know a side
effect of this is russian men are very
very angry and aggressive now that hub
is cut off yes yeah that's what started
us
all of a sudden everything was probably
right up until it's like ah we're
cutting you off we have no outlet have
you seen our women they don't shave
their pits all we have is long tables
you have number one export is showing
our number one expert is sending you our
women to be wives your number one expert
is sending us pictures to let us know we
have no more wives
we uh we send you a prettiest women yet
i am married to a mall with three hairs
on it yes this is very very strange
first place where is my bridget nielsen
gorgeous woman for five minutes yes and
kind of like the other one on top gun
you know lady from top gun yes you see
her now
not lazy
no i hide her under long table i throw
up in mouth yes a little bit that's also
because i wake up and go to sleep and
they have vodka morphine drips so it's
hard to know throw up but i think it's
partially from your ugly women but
here's the thing they're not wrong
they're not wrong these are shameful
exports from the west look and you can
also believe that people have the
freedom to engage in things that are
harmful
while also agreeing that they aren't
necessarily moral however russia doesn't
really have a leg to stand on because
they're the seventh worst nation in the
world
uh regarding human trafficking and you
know who's number one
she knows number one is their feeder
league belarus really number one
yeah
no and a huge portion of that is sex
trafficking but overall human
trafficking it's sort of hard to parse
out the information but still look i get
it i get that you don't this is what
they do they they try and tell their
people that we're upstanding moral
countries and that's propaganda and the
united states is not when the fact is
look these are not deeply rooted uh
christian
uh principles in russia there was a con
it was a distinctly basically a state
denomination of atheism for a long time
up until
really you're talking about the 1980s
1990s so
marxism lenin right too if you go go
through marx then lenin stalin was a
distinctly atheist ideology religion was
seen as harmful and now they're trying
to play catch-up and maybe people
feel this way but your country hasn't
caught up with it because you know what
centuries and decades of uh practice of
dogmatic atheism has its consequences so
don't disagree with the priest on
everything but uh he also should maybe
get on a pelican well i think one of the
things is you just remember they tend to
kill the people that are immoral in
those kinds of regimes and so you know
eventually you just you know you're
you're moral yeah exactly he gets on a
pelican with that robe you're gonna be a
mess my screen name is meant it's 44.
he's on pornhub
[Laughter]
it's just a vendetta he's like i am
telling you i tried pornhub that not
work it's like no one just no one wants
to watch you masturbate i don't know if
that's it that's it i just i'm doing
research all the time all the time
i am doing research as to why this oh
that's disgusting gross i better watch
it to the end yes that's the lion these
19 tabs are disgusting
i will open the window of disgusting to
confirm
filthy west devil
it's the most virus-filled computer
his computer has aids yes
this computer is just pop-ups
by the way uh
speaking of immoral it's time for us to
go out to our favorite state of new york
with some updates this is uh time for
this week's empire state of crime
[Music]
[Music]
okay so remember when the whole uh stop
asian hate was a thing remember that
it kind of went down the memory hole
along with i don't know kovid
it's weird it's weird
hand in hand i think it was daylight
savings or something i don't remember
set the punch forward yeah
so this was something that everyone was
complaining about right stop asian hate
and we talked about again of course you
shouldn't commit crime against asian
americans because of their race just
like you shouldn't commit crime against
any american well period and certainly
not because of their race however the
media was deliberately dishonest and
misleading as to statistically the
reality
regarding
the anti-asian
hate crimes the racially motivated
crimes the increase in violence which is
of course seen across the board in new
york but specifically
targeting asian americans so i warn you
for people who uh who are seeing this
it's we don't it doesn't get too graphic
but this is an important story to cover
uh new york
well this is yonkers uh there was a man
who punched a 67 year old asian-american
woman
125 times now look
i will never defend hitting a woman
right that being said if you're going to
lean toward that side
if i have to like i still i have i limit
it at 120.
i'll even allow 121 it's what i call the
gray strike but 125. i mean really 125
times to hit anybody it's like a
stabbing like you you should be in love
with them right you know what i mean
like you have to be like losing your
mind to punch somebody also what is he
what are these what are these criminals
in new york are they all on epo how do
you how do you throw 125 strikes i mean
who who has the time yeah
for crying with daylight savings we're
crying out loud tj dillashaw doesn't
throw 125 strikes at least he has a
minute between rounds so
this asian woman was struck 125 times
and take a guess
take a guess who the perpetrator was
we're going to begin with an attack so
brutal we had to freeze the video
because it's too graphic to show a 67
year old asian woman followed into her
building in yonkers and then beaten
relentlessly police say a man punched
and kicked her more than 130 times and
that man is now under arrest and charged
with a hate crime we're going to go
ahead and show you that video that
police tell us they released to
demonstrate the depravity of this crime
and to let the public know that hate of
any kind will not be tolerated but you
can see there the 67 year old asian
woman is pushing a grocery cart as she
enters her building in yonkers she stops
to open the second door of the building
vestibule when a man comes in behind her
and for absolutely no reason damn
launching her
second i thought it was called
the video at that point because what
happens after that it's hard for even
law enforcement to watch that man
proceeds to pummel the 67 year old woman
over and over and over again as you
mentioned more than 125 times he kicks
her he spits on her before leaving her
there on the ground
well it's hard for law enforcement to
watch but i guess it's not too hard for
your political representatives to watch
in new york right
because the policies that have led to
this
or did you forget about those did you
forget about cash and release did you
forget about no cash did you forget
about that
so let's go through some stats really
quickly uh ozil should have to watch
this like a clockwork orange with his
eyelids just ripped open because it is
his fault yeah he should be guerrilla
glued to a kaleidoscope
of just these crimes so that he realizes
the kinds of you don't get a mulligan on
defund the police you don't get a
mulligan on being soft on crime
leftist this is the direct result of
that statistically
that's that's the anecdotal that you
just saw and it should upset you you
should have a visceral reaction you
absolutely should but you can only go by
anecdotal because that's how people are
misled that's how people are led down
the primrose path so new york city alone
anti-asian crime has increased by 361
percent
or it did just in 2021.
uh now in 2018 there was a uh
there were some studies conducted and
keep in mind these are hard to find
because the doj
uh stopped actually
reporting the race of the perpetrator
and a lot of these crimes i can't
remember the doj or the fbi but we used
to be able to have these statistics and
then they just all of a sudden stopped
so this is done uh by uh this is done by
third party here one in four crimes
against asians were committed by a black
perpetrator more than any other race
keep in mind that it's disproportional
when you understand that they make up 12
of the population yes and i believe the
word is teens yes yes because that's
honestly what they would use in new york
there's like eight wanted teens and
you're like in their 40s yes okay
teens descending from yonkers right
weird
so this is again we can we can get into
uh how does this happen in the bay area
i think it was over 80 of all violent
crimes were actually blacks against
asians
now this isn't to say of course that all
black people commit crimes against
asians however people if you want to
defund the police police your own there
need to be organizations there need to
be protests specifically from the black
community saying hey let's stop this
violence let's stop this hate if you're
going to try and paint it as white
supremacy which is what they tried to do
this white house guess what
you don't get to the root cause of the
problem yeah i haven't seen any news
reports saying that there's a problem
like what we've just described we're
black men or or black teens as you put
it dave yes are attacking asians and
look i i really i mean men actually i
don't know
yeah exactly well they're just acting
like teenagers even though they're
supposed to be grown men at this time i
don't care what race is doing it but you
told us it was white supremacist you
told us it was a white person problem
and that donald trump in the white house
has led to more asian hate than ever
because of the wuhan viruses he said it
right the the virus that came from wuhan
right that's what you told us
and this is what we have show me the
video
of this happening in mass from white
guys and i am on your side you know what
else this does this gives ammo to our
enemy propaganda so for example in
russia they talk about they look they
want to vilify white people for
everything this is them trying to do an
ethnic cleansing right this is the kind
of rhetoric you hear from them and if
you go before these international
governing bodies and say black lives
matter makes it really easy for people
who as despicable as they may be
it makes it really easy for them to
highlight the truth and go look they're
not even acknowledging the problems in
their own community look they tell us to
fix our community they don't acknowledge
the 360 increase in crime and they blame
on white people do you want this coming
to your country fight the west this is
the problem with not being truthful it's
the only thing that matters when you are
trying to troubleshoot a problem and fix
it a couple of quick stats bail reform
coincided with a 40 increase in violent
crime over the past year
and they're gonna let this guy right out
right that's the amazing part yeah it's
it's a revolving door i mean you don't
it's what's bail oh it's zero great
right well the silver lining is he may
be held longer because he wasn't wearing
a mask oh thank god yeah he might i just
hope he was vaccine hesitant
we could lock him up for three hours
yeah
maybe five years yeah
that almost would be appropriate
wouldn't it you'd assume 20 but yeah
yeah uh and also let's not forget that
the new york may issue laws which
basically mean that you can't carry a
firearm in new york you have to have it
signed off by effectively a sheriff it's
one of those things it's an impossible
process which should not exist
or that barrier should not exist because
it is your fundamental right hey why is
it your fundamental right to carry a
firearm because of that
you can you can teach that woman martial
arts all she wants guess what she
doesn't have a chance yeah if you want
to save women the only chance they have
is a mechanical advantage the great
equalizer
that's that's why it's referred to
as that that woman is stronger than that
man let's not act like we can let's not
act like the left cares about women and
so bad the not allowing uh not allowing
all of its citizens to carry firearms so
what ends up happening this video i
believe just came out today
in new york city uh lines around the
block from asians
asian americans buying
pepper spray
this is again
a sign of how
concerned the community is it's all
mainly
women in line and elders and some elders
and because you know pepper spray is not
legal to buy here in new york as well
so
again
please stop
asian hate
yes so the uh rapid rise in crime across
the board with a significant increase
against asians in new york city cash
bail reform when you look at well bail
reform when you look at cash bail when
you look at the statistics regarding
black against asian crime i think this
may all just be a ploy
back to their old tricks it's big pepper
spray folks this has been empire state
of crime
[Music]
big pepper spray always up to their old
tricks
they win every time you know
if somebody had walked up and shot him
in that commission of the game that
would have been the appropriate outcome
and you know and i don't mean that like
i'm encouraging that i'm encouraging you
to protect the woman who goes oh i would
i encourage you kicked 100 if a woman
ever sometimes how about this
okay 67 year old woman you can't get
weaker than that yeah how can you at
what point is it considered am i
encouraging violence because i don't she
had brain bleeding by the way she's and
the report says she was mostly fine but
uh you know some facial fractures and oh
yeah brain bleeding the orbital was
shattered yeah yeah mostly fine minus
the 130 punches yeah what an ass but
here's 125 we don't want to exaggerate i
would only encourage violence
right after
look
how many first 10 20 strikes
maybe that 67 year old asian lady had it
coming okay who knows what she said 40
50
i think maybe you have a problem
60 70 we're getting into what i call the
potentially red zone where to code
orange 70 80 look you're walking on to
dice but by 110 strikes i think it's
okay to encourage the guy being shot is
that there is no i think right after the
one of the reasons nobody stepped in
i would imagine is they saw that's a big
guy like he wasn't some small dude going
out right suge knight is alive so
they're probably like oh i don't have a
firearm i can't fight off this big guy
what am i going to do just call the kids
the elevator you know what happens and
it's just some guy like all right just
going to close on yeah the closed door
which never works back up to third
getting it really hard
[Music]
that would be a terrible thing notice
also if it's a white guy walking by he
doesn't want to take the chance of
getting involved and being accused of a
hate crime oh of course well it's racist
if you save someone who's a minority
well they're not the most appreciated
minority i mean we can't let them into
stanford and harvard they're too many of
them yeah they're just good at being
them yeah they're just good at being you
know people why do we why do they hate i
don't understand they're good people
yeah well i like the food i like the
food yeah they can take a punch
apparently
yeah look if they're any other sick if
there are any 67 year old single males
it's hard to find a lady who can take a
punch these days so yep
geez prospect
just saying
as soon as one's face heals probably
never because she's 67 there's one
available yeah exactly
not to make light of it at all can we
bury this guy under the jail like this
is they're not going to do anything to
him that's a problem with new york this
all this is why i hated living there
there's violence constantly yeah and
it's a complete result of defund the
police like you said and then the bail
thing was the bail thing was just that
was the day they were like oh we can
just go to macy's and take whatever we
want yeah like it
like well no no it is frowned upon
it's not illegal but i'm sure the guilt
you feel is far worse than any
punishment we could administer look me
in the eyes look me in the eyes i was
outside eating and it was one of the
three places that survived yeah and i
was outside eating and there's just this
homeless guy and he's just uh touching
himself if you will like right in the
street and uh everybody's calling for
the police and the cop wrote up on a
horse and goes oh you don't like this
well maybe you shouldn't defund us
[Laughter]
and then rode away
and i was just crying
like yeah
it's like i can't do anything because of
you yeah enjoy enjoy enjoy your
dinner in a show yeah hopefully you have
one of the drinks with the tiny umbrella
but it was you're gonna i couldn't agree
with them more i was like this is what
we've been saying and it's just like
what we were talking about this is this
is the silver lining by the way the
silver lining you had eight years of
barack obama and former vice president
joe biden you had three four years i
don't really count the last year under
donald trump and now you're going to
have another four years of former vice
president joe biden the contrast is
important you can't say well it's just
new york city because new york city was
so safe it was almost disney world so
you had violent crime new york right you
had it violent and crime-ridden and we
said okay what's going on here far left
politicians for a long time then you had
the giuliani years where it was cleaned
up it became like disney world for
regardless of your opinions
statistically it's undeniable and now
we've gone to policies where there's
obviously a stark contrast it would be
one thing if it was always a violent
crap hole like detroit but they've
always had far left mayors since 1961.
new york tried both ways yeah it turns
out giuliani turns out batman and by the
way speaking of that uh it brings us to
an important story kyle rittenhouse you
know who's been here uh on the program
um sorry to bring you uh be the bearer
of bad news but his firearm the ar-15
was destroyed i believe yesterday
sometime this week here you go we have
footage do you recognize that weapon to
be the weapon you examined in the kyle
written house case
yes i do okay so pursuant to an
agreement between both parties and
approved by the court
the written house rifle will be
destroyed at the state crime laboratory
don't do that
auction it off
they're
rifle-less criminals in need
[Applause]
what is that thing doing shredding it
i believe it's a
witch you know there are rifleless
children in ukraine
yeah could have been put to good use now
uh we of course respect this was
actually kyle writtenhouse's decision
yes
he said it on our show uh decision to
have it destroyed and of course
i disagree with it but that's his choice
it's his choice to make and it is my
choice to at least decide to
honor the life of this rifle which
brings us to this week's
time to close
we were going up and we had stopped at a
store that was local kyla had also
wanted a gun
similar to the one i had he said he
would pay for it
so it kind of went on from there
[Music]
that looks like my
bicep being vaporized yes i mean you
have no idea
what mr rosenbaum was ever thinking at
any point in his life so your
interpretation of what he was trying to
do or what he was intending to do or
anything along those lines is complete
guesswork isn't it um
well he said [ __ ] you and then he
reached for the weapon
time to close
it's time to go to places where it
resembles the types of weapons that are
used in first-person shooter video games
this big long ar-15
very noteworthy
brah i'm just trying be famous
[Music]
do you recognize that weapon to be the
weapon you examined in the kyle written
house
yes
[Music]
comment below your favorite memory
of kyle rittenhouse's rifle
is that your friend in the wood chipper
there
yeah they fargoed that thing they did
they
didn't know that was possible yeah i
didn't know it was possible he's like
what are they doing chipping yeah for
crying out loud i mean just my first per
the first firearm ever purchased was
from a police auction i think they
should use it to uh put with chips on
playgrounds because that should uh
remind sex offenders yes
they should have a kyle writtenhouse
scarecrow at every local daycare and
they sent pieces of it around the
country
as a warning
hey by the way lottery with credit.com
tour dave and i are going to be in tulsa
oklahoma may 14th and we added a show in
colorado springs on june 18th so the
first one sold out pretty quickly and we
added a second show so people colorado
springs denver area get your ass on down
and uh dave is going to be uh in the uh
well i guess hartford connecticut the
funny bone this friday through saturday
yeah it's friday and saturday this
weekend i'm out to hartford uh or
manchester i guess it's technically in
oh jeez uh but yeah the manchester
hartford funny bone that's actually good
because i don't know if you know this
hartford connecticut you're you don't
you don't spend much time in the eastern
seaboard i don't think you hear hartford
connecticut what do you think
connecticut yeah you think probably nice
rich yeah yeah i think you could very
well be nice yeah
that's a rough day hartford is a rough
rough it's one part of connecticut that
didn't make it i know yes ah that's why
they don't talk like that they don't
talk like this they tell them oh what
what's happening uh you ever been mugged
[ __ ] oh well oh i'm bored and yeah get
my glove i can't smoke my mushroom
without my glove i had my fencing sword
but he still managed to punch me 125
times
one time lee was 124 too many well dave
be careful i will yeah i i grew up in
like he said detroit it's fine you know
where to go yeah
i know where not to go so now we move on
to a story here and i want to go through
all of this so you guys understand how
this affects you the macro because look
russia of russia ukraine regardless of
where you line up on what the united
states should do if they should be
involved at all
i don't think so i certainly don't want
to see us go to war i think you
i think it's completely reasonable i
think as a matter of fact uh i'd think
less of you if you weren't empathetic to
the people whose lives are being lost in
ukraine of course your heart breaks that
being said it's one corrupt
craphole fighting another more
aggressive corrupt crap that's that's my
opinion on it
but that's irrelevant to this discussion
okay
um i'm trying to think of the best way
let's start off with this you may know
that gensake met with influencers
tick-tockers to give them talking points
uh regarding the russia ukraine
narrative and this is not the first time
they've done it and there's of course
some subtext there that they decided to
meet with tick-tockers on a platform run
by the communist chinese party so they
feel safe in other words they feel safe
the white house feels safe enough
in
you know handing out the talking points
to people these influencers that they
may offend russia but not those in power
in china so that should tell you what
kind of a risk they're willing to take
here and who they're in bed with now
here is for those who don't believe me
again i'll reference the bill at
lotuscredit.com here uh here are a few
clips of these tick talkers
repeating the points
given to them admittedly from the white
house so i just got off of a zoom call
with the white house about the situation
in ukraine a number of other content
creators in social media and myself were
invited to this event which was on
background meaning that we couldn't
record or take pictures but we can
discuss what we learned from it second
russian troops are not happy with their
own invasions and it's really impacting
russia's ability to make progress in
this war
third russia is not going to win in
ukraine he's a star folks i had the
opportunity to ask the white house why
gas down the street is seven dollars and
here's what they said i'm glad to see
they
place emphasis on authoritative sources
yes goes up the price goes up let's get
an ass model to talk about
so how does that relate russia is one of
the top three producers of oil and it is
actually their number one revenue source
now with putin starting this horrific
fight between ukraine and russia nobody
wants to work with him and do an
international trade so these are the
people that the white house chose to
meet with now again what's really
important we'll get to the view and what
happens with legacy media but this just
shows you how low their standard is
remember they've always said it's about
authoritative sources yours truly has
been suspended from youtube for quoting
the cdc my bad they've said well you
can't take anything from uh from ladder
with crowder because it's not an
authoritative source no but all the
references that we provide every single
day are we don't even provide
conservative references it's either from
a neutral source if it's a scientific
paper or a journal or from a
left-leaning source we just use
washington post
or huffington post or new york times
just so you know that we're not the only
ones saying it so let's throw that out
the left doesn't care and certainly this
white house doesn't actually care about
authoritative sources or accurate
information do you know how i know you
can one of you got you want to ask me do
you know how i know how do you know
because here are some of the other
videos from these tick tockers
did white americans make clothes from
the skins of black people welcome to
episode 9 of hidden history
a march 17th
we can tell him yes right the doctor
wearing shoes made from the skin of
negroes it says that the doctor had no
symptoms about the matter and that he
thought he shouldn't be described as
acting through racial prejudice because
he wasn't your electoral journey and
fought to free black people in the civil
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a hot war who's terrible at dancing yeah
i know that's who you chose
[Music]
can i take this opportunity to uh this
is a public service announcement no more
mom jeans it's not flattering to anybody
i get that you think they're ironic you
look stupid
snl did the best it was with tina fey it
was so funny but now it's in style yeah
where chris parnell is just like looking
at his wife disgusted
[Laughter]
yeah they're not funny they're not
ironic i don't they're not uh just stop
yeah that's just that's a very very
attractive girl who can't even dance
look if you're very very attractive and
you just want to cut
cut your detractors off at the pass get
good at something just learn how to do
one dance well she can't even do that
but the white house has her own speed
dial like this is the person we want
communicating to everybody look i get
people i suggest being a mime i didn't
mean to interrupt you but i just would
appreciate it because she would not talk
and it's a skill yes
it is a skill we had a miami the other
day it is a skill yeah would have
preferred her to be in here but it would
have been better we probably would have
had better guesses yes i think but
you're telling me the the guy that's
this is the the next episode we just
talked to the white house and then the
guy that's like four on my list right
really these are the these are the
people that we're we're trusting for our
news yeah the star of asperger's nightly
yeah just like and number five and
number three battle star galactica now
number six goodness my virginity i'm
still in still intact the closet door
opens you just see someone fall through
with a ball gag stop i have to cut oh no
so here's the thing this is these are
this is funny because these are tick
talkers right okay and it's it's it's
easy target practice i understand
figuratively
now
this is not anything new a lot of you
may not know this but uh you know i sort
of under the sat under the tutelage of
andrew breitbart there was something
called journal list which existed under
the obama administration and that's
where a private google group of
left-wing journalists um
they basically were in touch with the
administration directly and they were of
course shaping stories and these were
journalists so in other words you have
tick talkers these were journalists and
this was actually originally leaked by
slate reporter i think it was um
i think it was a it was it was a
mickey mouse mickey house
krause
i don't know i don't remember his name
the reference is available you guys have
it there from daily caller
i can't get out of my head mickey mouse
i know it wasn't mickey mouse are you
sure but it sounded like it was mickey
something the point is it was slate
slate was like i think this is a little
too much slate yeah
not about a salon
or as pedophiles call it the place where
everybody knows your name
now the group journalists they were
conspiring actually um on how to attack
john mccain's campaign after he chose
sarah palin as vp so this is also an
important note when they say it was oh
it's donald trump because he's these
extremists is there anyone who's has
there ever been anyone in politics more
milk toast and inoffensive than john
mccain
they were conspiring to smear and attack
john mccain it doesn't matter
who you are it doesn't matter if you're
offensive it doesn't matter if you're a
donald trump they did it with george w
bush they did it with ronald reagan and
they did it with john mccain's campaign
again all the references are available
so there was a
campaign advisor to to this uh a barack
obama campaign advisor who was a member
there was also ezra klein he was a
founder there was matt iglesias jeffrey
tubin was on journalists
lieutenant fepper yes jeffrey metoobin
hey that would be great he's on the show
with j it should be jake it should be
tapper and fapper oh that'd be a good
idea
be like you know an angle like like all
the old crossfire no only it's just two
guys
servicing themselves on a same call it's
still crossfire yes it's still crosstalk
is only allowed from the neck up now
because jake tapper comes in and opens
an umbrella it just takes a while to get
to the point
so um well chris hayes was on it too
chris hayes was on this list journalist
and there was a member actually stelter
just comes in without the umbrella right
it just comes in with a bib
[Laughter]
so there was a member spencer ackerman
of the washington independent which is
great it's ironic and he shielded obama
from criticism this was actually uh
here's a quote from the christian
science monitor ackerman urged his
colleagues to deflect attention from
obama's relationship with wright by
changing the subject pick one of obama's
conservative critics mr ackerman wrote
fred barnes karl rove who cares and what
call them racists
wow this is what they said back then
just like now they're trying to say
putin apologists anyone who disagrees
with this exact narrative is a putin
apologist you can think putin is an ass
you can think putin is a power-hungry
oligarch and you could still think that
the united states shouldn't be sending
14 billion dollars abroad when we still
have starving veterans here yeah right
science denier putin apologist clinton
denier i mean we just all these things
just keep getting thrown at us right and
uh this is let me give you some other
examples this happened under the barack
obama administration and i just say that
because you know at this point uh we
have it now with saki but this is not
new so this is back when former vice
president was still former vice
president obama's spokesman jody uh
josh josh was it was it josh ernst ernst
josh ernst
bragged in an email
about uh ejecting fox reporters it says
uh here's a quote actually from judicial
watch i think saki gave you the run down
but the bottom line is we've
demonstrated our willingness and ability
to exclude fox news
from significant interviews but
yesterday we didn't they were lamenting
that then in 2009 i don't know if you
know this gen saki
she must be sucking the souls from a lot
of poddlings because she's still around
she was running 2009 as a director of
white house communications and in leaked
emails this is jen saki
these are her words
it's words i'm putting some dead fish in
the fox cubby just cuz
wow then she said uh correspondent brett
bear is a lunatic now keep in mind bret
baer is pretty damn moderate he's a
moderate conservative oh yeah
and uh this is not the only example dead
fish in the fox cubby yeah who did she
have sex with there right well i have
probably a lot isn't that what that
means i think so i don't know oh i could
be maybe i took that wrong and people
will say oh well they didn't bar them
from coming to the press conferences or
bar them from being able to be in the uh
in the white house to cover the price
you don't have to bar them all you have
to do is never call on them right all
you have to do is never care what they
all you have to do is not put them in
the demented old circus monkeys cue
cards that's 100 true that's true so
here's actually uh another example this
is more recent remember uh white house
jin saki so we have the tick tock we
have journalists we have examples of the
obama administration excluding voices of
dissent which is the same thing they
accuse donald trump of doing hey i don't
know if you know this but the only
actions that president trump took
against social media and he didn't do
enough i'm mad because he didn't do
enough he had a shot he blew it he
wanted them to allow all voices
he was not looking for them to eliminate
voices again look at the pattern here
there is a consistent pattern always of
eliminating voices of dissent whether
it's facebook whether it's
twitter whether it's instagram and the
white house supporting it here's
actually the white house and saki
encouraging
uh social media companies to flag posts
as misinformation well last july
you probably know but the surgeon
general also took the unprecedented step
to issue an advisor on the risk of
misinformation in public health which is
a very significant step and amid that he
talked about the role social media
platforms have so our hope is that all
major tech platforms and all major news
sources for that matter be responsible
and be vigilant to ensure the american
people have access to accurate
information on something as significant
they should go to tiptoe 19 that
certainly includes who determines
accuracy
we want every platform to continue doing
more to call out misinformants and
disinformation while also uplifting
accurate information oh those are nice
words do more to call out while
uplifting yeah you got us suspended from
youtube for quoting the cdc
correct they're inaccurate according to
that suspension
well and who i would think who got more
crap on social media than trump is there
anybody in the existence of mankind has
ever gotten i mean a sitting president
removed while the ayatollah khamenei is
still there right it's like how much
more damage can you possibly do yeah
well they're not even they're not even
afraid of it at this point but he's
willing to still take it though he's
like i just want it to be free so you
can keep you know keep shooting your
arrows at me right i still want it out
there they want the slightest things to
be sensed youtube removes interviews
with donald trump right think about that
not only do they want to remove statues
and this is remember where they were
saying okay we want to remove
confederate statues and people said okay
i kind of understand then donald trump
said what's good what's going to be next
abraham abraham lake and because he said
it people said oh he's being silly
abraham lincoln well then okay abraham
lincoln statute people want to remove
him and now you want to talk about
look it's just like this is just like
germany for a period of time banning the
teaching of history of what happened
under nazi germany i'm not saying that
the left is equivalent to nazis what i'm
saying is the approach
of banning portions of history that you
don't like
namely a presidency that you didn't like
of trying to remove now any interviews
with the former pres that was a
president who up until the freest and
most fair election of all time had more
votes than anybody in the history of the
country yeah are they banning interviews
with george w bush are they banning
interviews with uh jimmy carter for
crying out loud they didn't even ban
interviews with robert byrd who wasn't
president but he would have been forced
in line if the right planes had gone
down and he was in the clan he was a top
right he was basically ceo of the clan
well and just think about it this way if
you don't give the person a chance any
kind of platform to get the word out and
say look i've been i've been misquoted
play the tape to the end this is not
what i said this is not what i meant
here is what i meant they've taken that
away from donald trump completely on
this planet that's exactly the point and
then they want to tell you what it
should be so in other words let's just
not call on fox news let's just not call
on people who are critical would love to
see how many conservatives have been in
on those influencer meetings i don't
know if you know this this is the number
one conservative channel that's ever
existed on the biggest video platform
that's ever existed never been called on
once never been in any of those meetings
so i don't know who they're having there
if they're bringing in anyone from the
right but it's certainly not anybody
here
and then tell people what the truth is
so make sure the media doesn't show the
part where donald trump said i'm not
talking about neo-nazis or white
supremacists who should be condemned
totally but outside of that you had f
you had fine people on both sides who
were disagreeing they get rid of that
and then they tell you donald trump
praised white supremacists it's the soft
censorship and then the hard pushing of
a narrative and making it the only
permissible one and this is the irony in
that they are saying this is necessary
because of the crimes against humanity
that russia commits namely in silencing
voices of dissent and journalists so
here's another example this just took
place yesterday i believe the view
five hot flashes at a table called for
tucker carlson and tulsi gabbard to i
don't want to take it out of context i
don't want to take it out of context but
it sounds a lot like they're
supporting and by sounds a lot i mean
they are supporting the arrest and
punishment
of a speech from tucker carlson tulsi
gabbard and of course you if it's
something they don't like and i think
doj in the same way that it is uh
setting up a task force to investigate
oligarchs should look into people who
are russian propagandists and shilling
for putin they used to arrest people for
doing stuff like this if they thought
you were
uh colluding with a russian agent if
they thought you were putting out
information or taking information and
handing over to russia they used to
actually investigate stuff like this and
i guess now you know there seems to be
no bars no bars you mean rebar like they
have to reinforce your bed frame with
you they're no boss good to see you're
supporting mccarthyism there whoopee
yeah are there any bars nope nope
they're all in your chest just read the
hoodie child there are no bars i don't
know why they're not arresting them how
about they arrest you for your wardrobe
choice
oh i gotta buy big big clothes it's for
a man who's huge i get a tarp and then i
put a hoodie on it this is a poncho that
i put a logo on yeah saves money and
time when it's like steve jobs with a
black turtleneck only with me it's big
and fat hoodies child then you have anna
navarro sitting there she's just there
to give them credit right again they've
never ever had people like this program
on but anna navarro says i am a
republican i used to be cuban and i'm a
republican so you can trust what i say
arrest all the republicans yeah it is
unreal
my hoodie was supposed to say hope but
then it got all stretched out and ruined
by me
[Laughter]
i put my hat through a normal shirt it's
like stretching it out with a cantaloupe
job
i haven't washed my hair in five years
that's dandruff
and look at the word that she used by
the way she she said
no no no shilling for putin right yeah
you're out there shilling for putin
we're not gonna we're not talking about
this person right now but we just
mentioned him donald trump gave an
interview where he was describing that
putin is a very smart evil person he
said don't underestimate it which is
exactly what sunny hostin said so that's
an example you eliminate donald trump
from the pool where again you can go
watch his speech and you can go watch i
believe i don't remember if it was an
interview and then he reiterated it at
cpac but he said he's not he's not
stupid i'm just saying excuse me i
believe what i'm saying he's not stupid
he was saying don't underestimate them
then they told you that donald trump
support supported support
he was out there she was out there
shilling
they said that's the new term that they
use you should putin putin i guess at
this point but you were calling
everybody racist right back then it was
just just call them racist we just
showed you the emails just call them
racist and now today it's just call if
they don't want to go to war if they
don't want to spend
it'll probably it'll probably rack up to
tens of billions of dollars over the
long term here with this conflict if
they don't want to spend tens of
billions of dollars just call them putin
apologists so they eliminate donald
trump from that pool
they say he apologize he was a putin
apologist he was supporting putin then
sonny hoston says the exact same thing
on the view
and no one has a problem with it why
because she has a seat at the table
where she can provide the context which
they don't allow to political dissidence
and by the way they mention specifically
tulsi gabbard and tucker carlson
russian propagandists if they're if
they're russian plants as though they're
actually working for russia
look they may not follow the exact party
line of uh of whoopi in republic in
navarro but let me show you uh where
they've clarified their stance on russia
i don't know i don't know if they're
huge fans of putin but you be the judge
here are the undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according to the us government these bio
labs are conducting research on
dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities even in the best of
circumstances could easily be
compromised and release these deadly
pathogens biden official in charge of
ukraine confirming the bad news toria
newland the under secretary of state
casually mentioned in a senate hearing
on tuesday that actually yes the byte
administration does fund a series of bio
labs in ukraine and whatever is in these
labs is so dangerous that she's deeply
concerned these materials will fall into
the hands of the russian military
doesn't seem like they're thrilled about
either the bio labs which of course
people would say is a conspiracy uh or
getting into the hands of the russian
military which again would imply they're
not big fans of the russian military you
can also find more clips than you can
watch in a lifetime of tucker carlson
saying that he's not a fan of putin just
because he doesn't say that everything
putin does is wrong doesn't mean that
he's a supporter of them right well and
she's like yeah when you're shelling
buildings bio labs tend to have problems
because they tend to get out of bio labs
without shelling right and also when
power goes out there's a bad president
to have issues as well yes do we
understand how this works well thank god
the uh the uh nuclear plant being uh you
know bombed and on fire that the ukraine
released what turns out that that wasn't
a thing not a thing oh and i'm just
checking my notes here i just want to
say uh there's not a wet market near any
of these ukrainian bio labs no there are
we're good guys
it's fine it's everything's fine but
there isn't aldi's
oh no well
yeah yeah how do you get prices that low
well i don't know
i assume they just get the produce right
when it's about to spoil their produce
doesn't hold up very well now here's the
thing
that what they're doing right now where
they're saying you need to arrest uh or
we used to arrest that's mccarthyism and
by the way mccarthy wasn't wrong about
everything but whoopi and i would well
we wouldn't be able to have a
conversation about it but the point is
she's just
she's just blank slate supporting
mccarthyism it's very similar when you
look at what the white house is doing
and it's a scaled back version but
certainly of what the members of the hot
flash five want us to do
when you look at russia who are
arresting protesters for holding blank
signs
[Music]
that's lazy
yeah i mean it shouldn't be a surprise
to anybody again i'm not a fan of the
way russia handles handles critics or
the media it's the old russian joke
right if well the problem is so obvious
there's no need to write it down i love
that that's hilarious like it's so bad
and people know that it is so bad you
hold up like just the insert here
whatever whatever you want you know
what's going on
this is blank sign yes but we understand
with after effects you could key in
something you could put penis on there
with putin we have to get we can't take
chances
sharpie pulled out of russia too and
also crayola and so they're just like
what do we do
what crayola what will we do with our
military when we give them scissors they
need crayola safety scissors they're
always drunk they will stab each other
good yes
after eating suddenly sometimes they eat
lots of paste and take naps safety
scissors very important very importantly
it's standard issue it is standard issue
to our soldiers like the french army is
with individual white flag
well in solidarity i would just like to
uh
anything you want boy this is going to
backfire on you yes
mean that send it to me at s crowder on
twitter ah come and you know what not
only that if you are below uh if you're
on youtube comment below what you would
like to see memed come on on gerald's
white card please all entries are
welcome no no they're not all entries i
didn't think that through yeah no you
have no one to blame it yourself yeah
listen dave it's the price of freedom i
will stand in solidarity with them and
hold on i think you're going to find out
it's a hefty price
there's no rollback on this price
nope that is not an aldi pricing no it
is not my friend that's a whole boobs no
blank card for all of you
video evidence it's a blank card it's no
whole sale you are paying full retail
uh
to give you an idea by the way for
context about 14 000 russian uh
protesters have been arrested since the
beginning of the war and this is an
example right here of uh there was a
broadcaster a producer who busted in to
the room during a new show in russia and
again hats off to these people
for for trying to make their voice heard
and doing so understanding that there is
a serious
risk
and by the way uh her whereabouts were
on but then they found her just now
breaking news probably within the last
hour she has reappeared in a moscow
court because uh she's gonna
she's gotta go to court to defend the
well it's not quite as bad as holding up
a blank card that's going to be like the
dark knight court with uh what's his
name that actor who played scarecrow
like your choice is gulag or
gulag ah i would pick gulag that's right
i bet whoopi is so jealous yes
to beat russia we must become
russia yes at least whoopi becomes
russia that's what it is i feel like
i've to i feel like i'm having drago
today child oh i'd do a job
if he dies he dies child
it's the price you think hey hey gerald
i will break you chad really yeah so uh
here's the thing over there and this is
am i a chair is that how you're gonna
break me oh i just have the worst visual
over there by the way
it doesn't matter which side of the
conflict you're on this is the thing too
this is just what the united states here
uh is pushing take whoopi take what
they're talking about at the view take
what sachi is talking about and
accelerate it and you end up with russia
scale it back just let's go in reverse
russia okay scale it back australia
scale it back canada
scale it back mandates lockdowns right
there's a march people always say
there's a march towards totalitarianism
there's a march towards socialism but i
repeat myself there's a slow march and
you are definitely on that march when
you ban a sitting president so over
there they've gone around the bend where
it doesn't even matter which side of the
conflict you're on here's a clip of and
i shouldn't laugh
but i but i laughed really hard when
i've watched this it's almost as though
it's a it's almost timed like it's a
sketch so forgive me
regardless of what side of the conflict
you're on you you'll be arrested
wait for it
um
[Music]
this is a monty python sketch yeah just
keep talking how are these not all
russian women but how are those russian
women so dumb
they're looking at all the cops just
staring at them like
where are all these cops no ignore them
tell me what your opinion is are you
sure because usually if we talk we
disappear no no no no that's just an old
wives tale tell me your opinion
okay but if i talk it's like red rover
the cops are just boom running right in
i just love
just goading her into saying it and then
arresting her feel comfortable no you're
fine whatever we asked you your secret
is safe with me it's fine just tell me
and 19k gps these guys don't worry about
them they are invisible to you yes
just ignore the neck tattoo of grim
reaper holding baby yes it's just nice
it's just hannah terrible they had a
party at the office so you were saying
so stupid and then she even and she's
basically supportive of it they arrest
her anyway well they didn't know they
were saying cut the risk woman talking
[Laughter]
we should turn that into like an
impractical joker
yeah practical jokers in russia yeah
just
saying they're just getting dragged away
the women
were you in here for what hidden camera
show yes yes that's right uh i said the
wrong thing i was told to ask a hot dog
vendor for too much mustard apparently
that is joke between practical jokers
people find it hilarious it's really not
even just wasting mustard i didn't eat
the hot dog and they beat the [ __ ] out
they just saw the video in court is this
you yes uh too stupid yeah guilty killed
like a boinky sound effect
yeah
the judges the judge's mallet is just
one of those inflatables
i feel like it adds levity before i end
your life
it's an awfully serious sentence oh well
okay that's not right also do you like
my flower do you like hey yes don't get
closer look it's a lilac
it's water i like to have a love
so we we also have an update on uh the
woman who
protested on the live broadcast marina
ovis
yeah
right the one that i said appeared in a
moscow or cineco
yeah yeah i'm sorry joe got it ah yeah
already got on to update the update yeah
of the updater admonished okinawan
like he's in this room and he wasn't
paying attention iii
there we go hey
hey hey token did you notice that whoopi
goldberg was wearing a hoodie maybe you
want to fill us in on that
if he says what if he says nope yeah
nope
well played how to do it
so look this is the the point that i'm
making here this administration and of
course the administration before were uh
former vice president biden was vice
president before he was former vice
president
they have no qualms about trying to
manipulate the media they have no qualms
about trying to set a narrative they
have no qualms about eliminating voices
of dissent
and now they want to eliminate voices of
dissent
in discussing the conflict between a
country or between two countries and by
the way one of the primary sins of that
country russia is eliminating voices of
descent do you see the irony no this
these these people are putin apologists
so we need to make like a putin and kill
them
again scale it back
you think it's either you think it's
either you know as freezing can be like
a donald trump administration with the
press you know what the worst thing is
that would happen with donald trump if
he didn't he'd go no excuse me fake news
and they would say look he's just like
mussolini right yeah he just i mean just
use your own term back against you they
say turn around look at those guys those
are all fake news people right there
that you can't trust they're going to
say things about you that aren't true
and turns out they said things about us
that aren't true this is a genuine
question i want every and i know that
if you're watching right now or
listening that you you may be left of
center a lot a lot of people who watch
this are
can you objectively look at this right
now
look at the scenario look at the three
four years under in this in this case
include all four years of donald trump
and look at the media coverage look at
abc cbs nbc cnn msnbc even fox news to a
large degree outside of maybe two shows
and look at the criticism look at what
he had to put up with and i'm not saying
that all the criticism wasn't valid and
i'm certainly not saying that these
media outlets shouldn't be allowed to do
it for crying out loud i want stelter to
be tenured
and compare it to right now
can you honestly say that in the trump
years the media was muzzled the media
was silenced whereas right now
when you see what's happening yours
truly
this show removed for not only quoting
the cdc i think the other one we were
suspended because we supported the
police officer who shot makai brian who
by the way was just
just uh i don't know if he was found not
guilty or all charges were dropped they
don't know the exact legal nomenclature
here yeah but of course he was found to
be in the right shooting a girl who was
stabbing another girl where he said put
down the knife we were suspended for
praising that police officer
because it was considered reveling in
the death of someone who was about to
commit murder murder against someone
else
uh suspended for that
you see saki saying hey you know we want
them to crack down more on
misinformation regarding uh kovad19 and
now the same thing hey we want you to go
out there and push this message on
russia ukraine let's give you the
talking points can you honestly look at
can you honestly look at the treatment
of the donald trump administration
versus the treatment of this
administration and by proxy of course
the obama administration and not see a
difference and can you see how it's
dangerous here's why it's dangerous why
it's far more dangerous when you have a
democrat
in the white house when you have a
democrat or you have democrat controlled
let's say senate or house the reason
it's more dangerous is because you
already have far left controlled
everything else hollywood
the entire entertainment industry
media education all of it that's not
really the case in other words when
there's a republican in there when
there's a conservative in there guess
what they're still fighting upstream
with everything else when there's a
democrat in there it is lockstep across
the board where everyone is in agreement
and now the most powerful companies that
have ever existed in the history of
mankind just take five
you've got amazon you've got apple
you've got alphabet youtube you've got
alphabet meaning youtube and google
you've got facebook you've got twitter
you can toss microsoft in there and
these are the people who by the way
based on the white house's guidelines
it's easy to look at the tick talkers
but based on the white house guidelines
they're willing to ban
apps from their platform let alone
videos from youtube let alone pages from
facebook let alone shadow banning tweets
they all act in unison
at the very least can we all acknowledge
that there's a different dynamic of
checks and balances
when there's at least one lone
conservative voice even if it's just in
the white house which is not nearly as
powerful as a swamp in the media
entertainment industrial complex i mean
you want to know what happens look right
now trudeau is talking on cnn i want to
hear what this guy is saying and let's
see let's see if he's parroting the
lines that saki was giving the tick
talkers or if maybe he's a voice of
reason let's see what he has to say
ukrainians
are standing up to authoritarianism
and as parliamentarians you are
authoritarian today
you jailed pastors right
we stand with you as friends you can
count on our unwavering and steadfast
support two-spirited support and now it
is my great privilege
there must come a sweet music to you to
the ukrainian's ears like oh thank god
the canadians are here to save us we
were waiting for men in dog boat with
shotgun oh can we go there to be
arrested yes please send over your
pissed your piston planes with your
handguns
so they've got zielinski on he's he
addressed uh the british parliament
within the last week i can't remember
the true story of robin williams man of
the year yes
pretty much yeah it's crazy i like this
dude sorry if you guys well but i i find
them interesting i find them interesting
yeah i don't have like i guess it's a
strong word but i find them interesting
can you hitter me
oh sorry there's a virus getting out yes
i must close 18 cents prime minister
dear justin
members of the government
member of the parliament
[Music]
all distinguished guests
friends
before i begin i would like you to
understand
my feelings
and feelings of all ukrainians
as far as it is possible
our feelings over the last 20 days a
table has 20 days
of a full-scale aggression of russian
federation
after eight years of
fightings in donbass region can you only
imagine
[Music]
the canadians
each of you
you start hearing bomb explosions
severe explosion justin can you imagine
hearing
you your children hear all these prime
minister blackface yes you
bombing of airport bombing of ottawa
airport
tens of other cities of europe keep
keep in mind that uh prime minister
trudeau and this is actually an
important example i don't necessarily
you guys let me know if something
interesting takes place there it's
basically parenting the same lines uh
they did compare the freedom convoy
truckers to nazis yeah they treated them
as criminals and arrested them and by
the way again you don't need to just go
okay russia you don't need to just
compare russia to the united states
there are shades in between that okay go
back from russia you have australia you
have quarantined camps you have people
being arrested for simply walking
outside when they're not when they're
not within curfew
let's go to canada let's let's just
bring that back a little bit the cbc
just had to admit to misrepresenting and
reporting inaccurate information about
the freedom convoy those truckers in
canada keep in mind they were protesters
some of them were trampled by horses
the canadian government enacted
emergency powers that allowed them to
freeze their bank accounts is that
getting close to totalitarianism
think about that for a second by the way
the cbc who misreported the information
on the freedom convoy a lot of americans
you may not know this i grew up with
this the cbc stands for the canadian
broadcasting associate the canadian
broadcasting corporation i believe it's
a canadian broadcasting corporation
someone can bring up i know it's
canadian broadcasting i don't know what
the last c stands for and it receives
hundreds of millions of dollars in
government funding when trudeau ran for
office keep in mind prime minister
trudeau who was uh you know to be prime
minister trudeau at that point
he promised it was either 100 million or
150 million more in grants from the
government per year to cbc tell me
that's not going to taint the coverage
of the election
it's like a kid running for class
president promising free ice cream in
the cafeteria just promises cbc
basically
the only broadcast
network there that has a monopoly on
news and they misreported they just had
to admit it
because of independent journalism which
exists online but doesn't exist on
television there they had to admit it
because they got called on it and
they're funded by the government so you
scale it back you have russia you have
australia
you have canada and let me ask you this
do you really think for a second that
kamala harris the nancy pelosi the
jinsaki that joe biden wouldn't be like
the rest of europe wouldn't be like
australia wouldn't be like canada if
they could do you really think that
whoopi goldberg and anna nevarro di
republican
on the hot flash five view do you really
think for a second that they would stand
up for your rights to speak out against
the narrative
that they're setting
you really think it's that hard to
imagine so this is something that
all i'm asking is
for everyone out there to keep your eyes
open and by the way i also ask you to
smash that like button if you're
watching here on youtube because that
helps with the algorithm and youtube
keep in mind the reason youtube removed
the dislike button was entirely
entirely because of donald trump's
farewell speech and the likes versus joe
biden's acceptance speech
and no likes yeah yeah none whatsoever
yeah yeah it's good i thought you're
about to say something i thought you
raised your hand no
all right yeah okay are you having
visuals again i am
i was staring into the lights for too
long oh i moved my leg maybe that's what
it was oh that's what it was i thought
you did this i was trying to do the
charleston and my mom jesus you're
trying to do the challenge i want to get
invited to the white house well you are
a big glenn miller fan
so this brings us to something else and
by the way you can be banned on youtube
for this this next story that i'm about
to present to you that's why we just
asked that you go to lotterythrough.com
club or watch on rumble because we're
going to continue on this story
careful
careful
you're not laughing at her you're not
allowed to make fun of someone for their
immutable characteristics which
immutable means you know innate
characteristic characteristics you're
born with yeah uh and in this case it uh
can be someone who was born a man and
then put on a dress and a sideshow bob
wig or a twisted sister
toupee
and that is now off limits
so rachel kinnison yeah
beautiful and brave rachel levine
different
first by the way keep in mind it used to
be sex and gender were different
remember former vice president joe biden
said first female
admiral what first female admiral so now
well we've tied the two together which i
kind of warned you would happen it was
just a grammatical term and it was just
a way to use word play against you to
remove you of your basic fundamental
actual birthrights the right to speak
freely and the rights to say
if you're born a biological man i still
think you're a man you could be removed
on youtube for saying this do you still
feel free so rachel levine the first
female admiral uh is among usa today's
women of the year oh she's the candidate
oh wow who's that lady
sexy lady who's that elated beautiful
later i would just love i wonder if you
know what tom jones singing at his
concert and then rachel levine walks up
she's a lady
[Music]
talking about that freaking lady and i
guess the balls are fine
[Applause]
who's that late
lady i guess it's maybe
oh that lovely maybe that lady is
mine do you think he plays aerosmith's
song once
twice
three times a
maybe three times a healing after
surgery yeah i did
transitional healing
not even gonna say what i was gonna say
it's just gonna get us banded
in red
your wound is opening
so usa today's women of the year
too far
other honorees include kamala harris
that doesn't really no no it matters why
would you nominate kamala harris what
did she do she got selected as being the
you know worst presidential candidate in
the primaries possible in the voting but
she got selected to be that and then
simone biles i think her claim to fame
this year simone bile is an amazing
athlete her claim to fame not this year
within the last i guess couple of years
was actually backing out of the olympics
essentially and and having kind of a
breakdown yeah that's she uh she would
have been woman of the year when she won
and when she was doing those things and
that's a hundred percent funny well they
couldn't that slot was filled with
caitlyn jenner yeah oh true yeah
they can't all be women of the year
gerald i think simone biles is awesome
i'm just saying
what are we what are we rewarding there
well the good thing is she got to she
was rewarded with a lucrative contract
with subway
on those commercials now yeah that's
pretty good like sometimes to be fresh
you gotta refresh are you admitting that
you've run your company into the ground
with listeria how do you get that where
you sit somebody down and go listen um
yeah our old sponsor
[Laughter]
is the guy spokesperson if you will yeah
oh anyway can you not uh
can you do this without touching kids
let's get a woman what's this let's do
something yeah this is something i don't
know oh the old sponsor yeah jared i
know he used to come to our gymnastics
lessons yes oh lord yeah then we went
when we turned 18 yeah and we just never
saw him again never saw him or the pants
he would always hold up look look these
with my pants we're like we don't care
we should probably not tie our brand to
gymnasts either there's too much stuff
there's a lot going on there's the
michigan state doctor is the new subway
speaker
altar boys let's go there played by john
lovitz yeah subway eat fresh so this
isn't the first female award that levine
has received uh i don't know who could
forget gerald remember when of course
not this was the first female four-star
admiral yeah yeah yeah that was first
one in in history right
when the war was over
there were jobs galore
for the hunky sailors
who were in the war
for some admirals things were not so
grand
[Applause]
and the navy could not understand
[Music]
what do you do with an admiral when he
stops being an admiral oh what do you do
with an admiral ray aside
who's got a job for a former man when he
starts being a lady and they all get a
job but a [ __ ] man no one hired
they fill his tits with medals
for fighting wars abroad
and spread the crimson carpet
for fighting as abroad
the next day someone hollers when he
she comes into view
here comes the admiral
and they all say
admiral who
they're delighted that he came
but they can't recall his name
his staff started maligning him
after gender reassigning him
it seems this country never has enjoyed
so many one and two and three and four
trans admirals unemployed
bye